invités politiques ce matin c'est ian
brossât bonjour je vous remercie
beaucoup d'être avec nous vous êtes
adjoint à la maire de paris anne hidalgo
cette porte parole du parti communiste
et on est ensemble pendant 20 minutes
pour une interview en partenariat avec
la presse quotidienne régionale
représenté par pascal jalabert selon
pascal du groupe ebra les journaux
régionaux de l'est de la france
on commence évidemment ian brossât par
cette longue interview d'emmanuel macron
ce matin dans le figaro on va rentrer
dans le détail on va revenir sur les
annonces et il y en a mais d'abord
qu'est ce que vous pensez du choix du
chef de l'état de donner une longue
interview sur le thème de la sécurité ce
matin pour moi je ne suis pas choqué que
le président de la république parle des
questions de sécurité et de lutte contre
la délinquance ce sont des questions qui
effectivement sont des questions
importantes
moi je suis élu d'un arrondissement de
paris qui est un arrondissement
populaire le 18e l'arrondissement de la
goutte d'or de la porte de la chapelle
et ce sont ses vrais des préoccupations
essentielles pour bon nombre de nos de
nos concitoyens et donc que le président
de la république prenne la parole sur ce
sujet c'est parfaitement légitime après
le problème c'est qu'il est au pouvoir
depuis quatre ans maintenant et donc il
a des comptes à rendre sur le sujet et
que les annonces qu'il fait peuvent être
mises au regard de ce qu'il n'a pas fait
pendant ces quatre années sur sur une
question aussi importante notamment sur
quoi on va parler des gérants fils fille
commençant son interview par ça alors il
dit qu'il ya une augmentation des
violences envers les personnes
augmentation de la violence du quotidien
notamment envers les personnes
dépositaires de l'autorité publique
notamment les policiers notamment les
élus aussi il dit cette phrase la
violence s'ancre d'abord dans les
quartiers les plus pauvres parfois
délaissés au point que les difficultés
économiques et sociales sont en piste et
elle touche d'abord les plus modestes je
me bats pour le droit à la vie paisible
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec cela
bien sûr est la question de l'insécurité
est une question qui pourrit la vie de
bon nombre de quartiers populaires
d'habitants qui ont des tout petits
revenus qui n'ont pas le choix de
déménager qui parfois vivent la peur au
ventre quand je vous le dis j'ai
évidemment des des visages en tête des
gens qui viennent me voir et qui me
disent qu'ils n'en peuvent plus de la
situation de leurs cités ou ou de leur
quartier donc évidemment qu'on a besoin
de réponses
ce sont des réponses qui doivent être
bien sûr des réponses à répressive et
donc on a besoin
de lutter contre les trafics notamment
qui pourrissent la vie des habitants et
on a dans le même temps aussi besoin de
mesures qui sont des mesures à plus long
terme moi je suis fait je convainque oui
on va revenir sur les trafics mais
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui il ya des zones de
non droit en france je ne sais pas si 6
il faut appeler ça comme ça ce sont des
formules qu'on a beaucoup entendu
notamment dans la bouche de de nicolas
sarkozy ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il y à
des endroits dans lesquels par exemple
on a un manque cruel de présence
policière moi c'est ça qui me frappe
dans le discours contient sur ce sujet
ce qu emmanuel macron dit il faut plus
de policiers vaut plus de bleu d'accord
sauf que le nombre d'habitants qui me
parle à moi comme élu local et qui me
disent on appelle le commissariat et les
policiers ne viennent jamais jamais et
quand je viens au commissariat on ne
prend pas ma plainte
c'est ça quand même la réalité concrète
vécue par d'état d'habitants donc c'est
très bien les paroles verbales les
grandes déclarations mais ce qu'on vit
concrètement dans les quartiers
populaires c'est ça c'est ça
et donc on a besoin de réponses
concrètes à ce problème concret et
emmanuel macron il se trouve qu'il est
président de la république depuis quatre
ans donc qu'il rende des comptes sur ce
sujet là qui est un vrai sujet de vie
quotidienne sur les trafics de
stupéfiants dont qu'il a dit pas une
minute pour les trafiquants
d'autres disent il faut dépénaliser le
cannabis puisque c'est quand même le
premier objet de trafic
quelle est votre position là dessus je
dois dire que j'ai un peu évolué sur le
sujet comme beaucoup de gens j'étais
plutôt hostile à toute logique de
dépénalisation et dans le même temps ce
que je vois c'est que le trafic a pris
une part énorme dans bon nombre de
quartiers et que donc on doit quand même
partir d'un constat c'est que la france
est l'un des pays qui répriment le plus
lusage de de drogue et l usage du
cannabis et dans le même temps c'est un
des pays dans lesquels on en consomme le
plus donc à un moment donné quand on a
une politique publique qui ne fonctionne
pas il faut en tirer un certain nombre
de conséquences et donc je n'ai pas
d'avis tranché sur le sujet à l'heure où
je vous parle
mais je pense qu'il serait légitime
d'ouvrir le débat ce que je regrette
c'est qu'il veut faire donc ça vous dit
c'est un an
ouvrir le débat dans une ferme
immédiatement la porte puisqu'il dit que
de toute façon il est hostile à toute
forme de dépénalisation ce que je dis
c'est qu'on avait dire que pour vous il
faut pas uniquement débat sur la
consommation et sur les effets délétères
comme il le propose mais il faut poser
la question de ce qu'il faut poser cette
question et je pense qu'on a besoin d'un
débat sur ce sujet qui seront un débat
sérieux
guidés par le pragmatisme le problème
sur ce sujet c'est qu'on fait des
symboles or on ne mène pas une politique
publique avec des symboles uniquement si
on cherche à trouver des solutions
notamment pour ses quartiers qui sont
gangrénés par le trafic
il faut être guidé par le pragmatisme et
donc je pense qu'il serait utile qu'on
ait un vrai débat sur le sujet un débat
informé un débat instruits qui soit
autre chose qu'une joute verbale entre
gens qui veulent faire des symboles sur
la réponse pénale puisqu'il en parle
aussi il ya le verdict ce qui est tombé
dans la sphère des 13 jeunes accusés
d'avoir attaqué et brûlé des policiers à
coups de cocktails molotov à viry
châtillon et cinq condamnations 8
acquittement ce sont des peines moins
lourdes que les peines prononcées en
première instance
emmanuel macron il dit il faut lutter
contre toute forme d'impunité est ce que
dans cette affaire vous dites que la
justice a été laxiste
je n'aime pas beaucoup me m'immiscer
dans des jugements
bon je suis pas juge en l'occurrence je
crois que c'était un tribunal populaire
d'ailleurs comment dire d'abord je veux
exprimer ma solidarité avec les
policiers les familles de policiers
parce que on n'a pas subi faire des
choses pareilles quand on exerce tout
simplement son métier
pour le reste sur ce jugement là je ne
prononcerai pas ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'on ne peut pas accepter que des
policiers soient traités comme ça et que
lorsque des événements comme cela
intervienne on a besoin de peine qui
soit des peines exemplaires et ce qui
s'est passé effectivement pose un
certain nombre de questions et ne peut
satisfaire personne mais c'est pas mon
message envoyé par l'egypte c'est
évidemment un message qui qui pose
question et qui doit être vécu comme
comme une douleur terrible pour pour les
familles de victimes évidemment gérald
darmanin raison de recevoir les
policiers cette semaine comme il l'a
annoncé
q le fasse c'est normal un mot juste sur
les forces de l'ordre parce qu'il défend
les forces de l'ordre emmanuel macron
dans cette interview mais il dit aussi
qu'il faut tirer toutes les conséquences
disciplinaires quand il ya un rapport à
charge que ce n'est pas toujours le cas
qu'il faut rendre public ce rapport à
charge
est-ce que là dessus vous approuver ce
qu'il dit oui mais mais mais je vous le
redis
le problème c'est qu'on manque d'une
vraie police de proximité dans nos
quartiers au parti communiste nous
proposons la création d'une police
nationale de proximité composée de
trente mille hommes et femmes chargés de
garantir la sécurité dans nos quartiers
on a besoin de recréer une vraie police
de proximité et je suis convaincu que
c'est aussi comme cela qu'on apaisera
les tensions qui existent aujourd'hui
entre la police et la population on a
besoin de policiers qui connaissent les
quartiers qui connaissent les habitants
qui connaissent les territoires et cela
on en a plus et on a aujourd'hui des
habitants qui sont démunis face à ces
phénomènes d'insécurité dont je pense
que c'est ça le sujet un dernier mot sur
cette interview il reparle de la sphère
sarah halimi la cour de cassation qui a
donc décidé qu'il n'y aurait pas de
procès d' pour cause d'irresponsabilité
pénale du meurtrier manuel mal qu'ont
ils dit décidé de prendre des
stupéfiants et devenir alors comme un
fou ne devrait pas à mes yeux supprimer
votre responsabilité pénale
il souhaite changer la loi ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec ça je n'aime pas
beaucoup les lois de circonstance alors
là de fait c'est une c'est une nouvelle
circonstance
enfin comme beaucoup ce jugement m'a
laissé un peu pantois donc comment dire
qu'on mène une réflexion sur ce sujet
pourquoi pas en tirer la conséquence
qu'il faut changer la loi dès à présent
ça me paraît aller un peu vite en
besogne
un autre sujet c'est dans le journal du
dimanche cette fois marlène chapelle
annonce qu'elle lancera devant les états
généraux de la laïcité des tables rondes
des conférences
elle dit que les partis politiques sont
libres de s'y associer à ce que le parti
communiste a sciemment mieux enfin
comment dire on sort d'une loi soit le
séparatisme et maintenant marlène
schiappa d'où sort les états généraux de
la laïcité nan mais sérieusement fin je
sais bien que marlène schiappa un
ministère croupion et qu'elle est
obligée tous les matins de créer le buzz
médiatique pour faire croire qu'elle
travaille enfin en l'occurrence ça n'a
aucun sens et à la loi de 1905
appliquons la loi de 1905
on a
besoin tous les jours de remettre une
pièce dans la machine sur le sujet moi
je suis profondément laïque et le parti
communiste est profondément attaché à la
laïcité m'enfin maintenant nous raconter
qu'on va faire des états généraux de la
laïcité un an de l'élection
présidentielle enfin comment dire c'est
c'est même plus une ficelle c'est une
corde tellement elle est épaisse non
c'est ça ça devient ridicule donc que
marlène schiappa essaye de faire son
travail correctement plutôt que d'agiter
en permanence le buzz média j'ai fait
pas mal si adli mais non mais elle est
en permanence dans la recherche du du
buzz de la polémique
enfin franchement c'est pas sérieux
c'est pas sérieux ça servait à quoi de
faire voter une loi séparatisme si c'est
pour nous ressortir des états généraux
de la laïcité une semaine après enfin à
quoi ça ressemble donc vous dirai pas on
a bien compris on va parler de la
réunion de la gauche avant de parler du
programme avec pascal c'est vous qui y
est allé un pur l'absolu communiste à
cette grande réunion de la gauche alors
au delà de la belle photo de famille
qu'on a vu fabien roussel lui dit que le
problème de la gauche c'est pas sa
division mais c'est sa faiblesse du coup
en quoi cette image d'unité qu'on a vu
samedi la solution c'est toujours utile
de se rencontrer de discuter de
confronter les points de vue mais moi je
suis totalement d'accord
ce qu'il nous faut surprendra pas avec
avec fabien roussel fabien roussel a
raison le problème de la gauche
aujourd'hui ce paquet les disperser
c'est qu'elle ne parle pas aux
catégories populaires que ce qu'elle dit
ne correspond pas aux attentes des
ouvriers des employés de ceux qui
veulent simplement vivre dignement de
leur travail
qu'est-ce qu'on encaisse qu'on a entendu
de la part de la gauche ces dernières
semaines des polémiques inutiles sur les
questions identitaires me croyais que
l'ouvrier qui 3 qui qui travaillent en
trois-huit sa préoccupation c'est les
réunions non mixtes il en a rien à faire
des réunions non mixtes donc le problème
c'est que la gauche elle doit renouer
avec les catégories populaires et pour
renouer avec les catégories populaires
il faut qu'elle parle emplois il faut
qu'elle parle pouvoir d'achat il faut
qu'elle parle d industrialisation autant
de sujets sur lesquels on n'entend pas
la gauche
donc même si on se mettait d'accord sur
un candidat commun si ce candidat commun
ne parle pas de la question sociale ne
refait pas de cette question là la
question clé il sera à côté de la plaque
justement j'ai ou cité 5 point de
croissance contre les croissance
réunion réservée par genre ou
universalisme de la laïcité traités
européens ou souveraineté nationale
nucléaire pas nucléaire pouvez-vous et
concilier sur ses poils là c'est ce
qu'il faut mesurer et ce qui est sûr
c'est qu'une union qui ne répondent pas
précisément à ces questions là est une
union qui serait en réalité totalement
artificielle donc avant de créer un
rassemblement il faut se mettre au clair
sur ces sujets pour tout vous dire je ne
pense pas qu'aujourd'hui sur un certain
nombre de sujets fondamentaux notamment
sur la question de l'union européenne
qui n'est quand même pas une petite
question et ça fait un certain temps que
ça dure la gauche a besoin de se mettre
au clair est-ce que c'est impossible je
ne le pense pas mais en tout cas il y as
besoin de discuter que je souhaite
d'ailleurs que six lits à d'autres
réunions on puisse aborder le fond de
ces questions ce qui n'a pas été le cas
samedi dernier
ici il y en a une qui est prévue fin mai
mais moi je souhaite qu'elle soit
l'occasion justement de poser sur la
table ces enjeux là et que notamment sur
les sujets dont je vous parlais tout à
l'heure sur la question du travail du
pouvoir d'achat et de la vie des
catégories populaires on puisse avoir
les propositions des uns et des saints
le parti communiste a des propositions
et il a vocation à les partager
ça veut dire qu'il faut s'accorder sur
un programme un candidat et même sur
législatives bon sens et ça marche
on en est pas là on n'est pas loin on
n'en est pas là et c'est la raison pour
laquelle c'est d'un jeune homme
oui je vous dis que la discussion
préalable c'est de parler du fond et
c'est de parler de ces sujets des gens
qui se mettent d'accord de manière
artificielle et qui en réalité n'aborde
pas les sujets de fond qui concerne les
français ce serait une union vouée à
l'échec
donc commençons par parler du fond parce
que quand même je vous disais tout à
l'heure la gauche ne parle pas
suffisamment aux catégories populaires
aujourd'hui dans les dernières enquêtes
d'opinion la gauche tous confondus
c'est un électeur sur quatre est encore
un électeur sur quatre parmi ceux qui
vont voter et ce sont les catégories
populaires qui vote le moins et qu'ils
s'abstiennent le plus de
autre sujet à nous et c'est la raison
d'être de la candidature de fabien
roussel à l'élection présidentielle
c'est de parler à ces catégories là
c'est de faire revenir aux urnes ces
catégories qui se sont détournés sur
l'affiché jean-henri de chez marine le
pen parle mais c'est le problème c'est
le problème
moi je ne me résous pas à ce que la
question sociale soit aujourd'hui captée
par marine le pen alors qu'elle n'a pas
de proposition sérieuse sur le sujet et
ce que nous voulons faire avec fabien
roussel avec le parti communiste c'est
remettre la question sociale au coeur
remettre la question du travail au coeur
et porter des propositions concrètes et
c'est ce que le candidat communiste ça
risque par d'éparpiller les voit comme
comme ce fut un peu le cas aux
européennes avec vous-même et aux
législatives
oui mais d'abord les airs et l'utilité
de d'abord les élections présidentielle
et les élections législatives sont deux
élections différente je pense que nous
aurons un candidat à l'élection
présidentielle ce sont les communistes
les adhérents qui en décideront d'ici le
9 mai prochain
ma conviction c'est que lorsqu'on est
une force politique nationale
on a vocation à être présent à
l'élection qui structurent la vie
politique française est donc le parti
communiste il a besoin d'être présent à
l'élection présidentielle pour porter
ses propositions sur les sujets dont je
vous ai parlé ça ne doit pas nous
empêcher pour autant de travailler à la
perspective des élections législatives
et ce sera à mon sens plus facile de se
mettre d'accord entre forces de gauche
aux élections législatives sur 577
circonscriptions que sur un non à
l'élection présidentielle donc ça veut
dire vous nous dites matin il n'y aura
pas un seul candidat de la gauche à la
presse je ne vois pas bien comment il
pourrait y avoir un candidat de la
gauche à l'élection présidentielle mais
pas du fait uniquement du parti
communiste jean luc mélenchon est
candidat est ce qui nous laisse croire
qu'il ne le sera plus demain
évidemment non les verts ont une
primaire et j'imagine que leur primaire
est fait pour désigner un candidat à
l'élection présidentielle
ou alors c'est juste une primaire pour
rire parti communiste effectivement à un
candidat donc m'expliquer qu'à cause du
parti communiste il n'y a pas de
candidat unique ce pas vrai
les autres forces politiques ont décidé
d'avoir un candidat est d'ailleurs par
le passé il est arrivé que à l'élection
présidentielle on est plusieurs camps
ida et ça n'a pas empêché françois
mitterrand d'être élu ou françois
hollande d'être élu donc le problème
c'est pas la multiplicité des candidats
le problème c'est la faiblesse globale
de la gauche le problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui la gauche tout faire on a
quand même empêché d'être au second tour
en 2002 s'est tenue une formation des
candidats
oui parce que du coup là ça risque pas
de faire la même chose je pense que
résumer le problème des difficultés de
la gauche à cette dispersion ça n'est
pas la réalité
le problème c'est qu'on ne parle pas des
problèmes des gens et qu'on doit
remettre ces problèmes là au coeur du
débat politique si tout le débat
politique portent sur des questions
anecdotiques plutôt que sur la question
sociale la gauche ne peut de toute façon
pas gagné 1 1 mo/s que six à sept
candidates pour le coup c'est anne
hidalgo don vous êtes l'adjoint ce que
si faute dans vos réunions de gauche
vous mettait d'accord sur la candidature
d'algos est ce que là pour vous ça ça
serait une solution il est ce que là
vous vous retiriez en dix ans mais mon
candidat c'est comment son soutien du
dalo mon candidat c'est c'est fabien
roussel et ça ne m'empêche pas d'avoir
la plus grande estime et la plus grande
amitié pour anne hidalgo don je suis
l'adjoint depuis 2014 et j'en suis
d'ailleurs très heureux mais mon
candidat c'est le candidat du parti
communiste et c'est fabien roussel
puisque vous l'avez cité jean luc
mélenchon et états d'amérique du sud
samedi
est-ce que sa place était là bas ou à la
réunion des gauches
je n'ai pas envie de polémiquer là
dessus par ailleurs la france insoumise
étaient présentes à la réunion de samedi
avec eric coquerel qu'il a bien défendu
et je suis pas choqué que que jean luc
mélenchon fasse de la politique en
amérique du sud il a parfaitement le
droit de le faire
travaux sur les régionales en île de
france
vous partirez à trois listes séparées il
n'y a pas d'accord possible pour vous
non l'essentiel c'est qu'on se mettre
d'accord au deuxième tour
moi je soutiens comme les communistes la
liste de clémentine autain puisqu'il ya
un accord entre nous il ya effectivement
trois listes comme la dernière fois
d'ailleurs l'essentiel c'est qu'on se
retrouve au deuxième tour et qu'on se
met en situation de battre
valérie pécresse et je fais adjoint au
logement à la mairie de paris leyrit
pécresse elle a divisé par trois les
crédits au logement social par trois
alors qu'on a six cent mille demandeurs
de logements sociaux dans la région ile
de france
donc la gauche aurait des choses à dire
et je souhaite qu'elle puisse les porter
au deuxième tour et qu'elle puisse
gagner un dernier mot sur un john avant
de parler de la crise sanitaire avec
pascal plus largement le parti
communiste sera tête de liste dans
combien de régions parti communiste il
est tête de liste en auvergne
rhône-alpes et tête de liste en
normandie avec respectivement cécile
cukierman et sébastien jumel et je crois
qu'on est tête de liste en corse aussi
il ya des régions où il ya encore des
noms enfin oui on finalise mai mais pour
l'essentiel les dés sont jetés
on en parlait avec les salles et eric
pascal fouet alors on rouvre les écoles
bien à une semaine les collégiens de
semaine c'est risqué où il faut le faire
je suis comme beaucoup de français et
j'en ai marre et donc je souhaite
évidemment que la vie reprenne
simplement pour que la vie reprenne dans
des conditions convenables tout le monde
le sait la clé c'est la vaccination et
le rythme de vaccination
malgré les grandes déclarations du
premier ministre reste quand même
extrêmement mesure est timorais on a
fait le calcul à paris si on continue à
vacciner à ce rythme il va falloir qu'on
attend d'un an avant d'avoir vacciner
toute la population de moins de 18 ans
c'est à dire un million quatre cent
mille personnes de plus de 18 ans pardon
c'est quand même préoccupant et donc moi
je pense que on aurait besoin
d'accélérer en matière de vaccination et
ce pas uniquement une question de
création de vaccinodromes c'est une
question de dose on manque de doses
c'est la raison pour laquelle avec
fabien roussel et avec le parti
communiste nous prônons le fait que l'on
puisse lever les brevets sur les vaccins
pour qu'on puisse produire beaucoup plus
de vaccins et qu'on ne dépendent pas de
l'industrie pharmaceutique comme c'est
le cas aujourd'hui pour
la production de vaccins libérons la
production de vaccins et vaccinés au
maximum c'est uniquement un problème de
12 ou c'est aussi un problème de
stratégie on a vu un des vagues
cynodrome avec peu de candidats au
vaccin à nice notamment on a vu ça à
paris aussi il ya eu des des endroits où
les gens ne viennent pas se faire
vacciner notamment parce qu'ils ont peur
d'astrazeneca
est-ce qu'il faut changer la stratégie
vaccinale et ouvrir la vaccination à
tous ceux qui le veulent
oui ça je pense qu'il faudrait le faire
enfin le problème du nombre de doses est
un problème quand même quand vous voyez
que par exemple sur la question des
enseignants rien n'a bougé
si ça continue comme ça on va vacciner
les enseignants pendant les vacances
d'été
enfin c'est vrai donc on aurait plus de
55 oui mais oui d'accord mais enfin il
ya des enseignants qui sont quand même
un peu plus jeune et il aurait à mon
sens le droit de se faire de se faire
vacciner donc non on a quand même un
problème de dos et nous vivons tous les
jours à paris avec des gens qui sont
frustrés de ne pas pouvoir se faire
vacciner faute de doses il fait même pas
sanitaires pour que ça reprenne plus
vite les secteurs n'y suis pas hostile
par principe en tout cas je n'y suis pas
hostile par principe mais enfin ça
suppose que ceux qui veulent se faire
vacciner puisse se faire vacciner
on va terminer en parlant de l'est de
cette nuit alors paris et salle on voit
des travaux partout des chaussées
défoncées
bref beaucoup de critiques que répondez
vous à ces critiques
moi je suis toujours pour qu'on entende
les critiquer je ne valais rien d'un
revers de main simplement je voudrais
juste faire une remarque c'est que on
entendait les mêmes critiques il y a un
an
on entendait les mêmes critiques il y a
deux ans et ça n'a pas empêché anne
hidalgo d'être très largement élu aux
dernières élections c'est plus simple
quand on se promène dans les rues
franches on
on assure les gens à qui j'ai hâte un
rachat d'ati disais exactement la même
chose pendant la campagne des élections
municipales
elle a d'ailleurs fait toute sa campagne
municipale sur ce sujet et il se trouve
que les parisiens n'ont pas voté pour
elle
ils ont voté en majorité pour anne
hidalgo donc je suis prêt à entendre
toutes les critiques
et d'ailleurs il faudra apporter des
solutions concrètes à cette question de
la propreté notamment c'est chose faite
puisque l'adjoint à la propreté mon ami
colombe brossel a proposé avec la maire
de paris la décentralisation vers les
mairies d'arrondissement de cette
gestion de la propreté mais enfin il
faut pas caricaturer non plus parce que
si paris était une ville à ce point en
situation apocalyptique d'abord anne
hidalgo n'aurait pas été réélu comme
elle l'a été et par ailleurs les
logements ne se vendrait pas à 10000
euros du mètre carré parce que personne
ne payerai 10000 euros du mètre carré
pour vivre dans une ville invivable ou
alors les gens sont complètement fou ce
que je veux dire c'est qu'il faut faire
preuve d'un peu de d'un peu de mesure
dans cette affaire mais ça ne doit pas
nous interdire de progresser allez on va
parler logement justement pour terminer
on va parler d'airbnb ans et un dossier
vous suivez bien évidemment vous les
décos tard pour les locations meublées
touristique dans certains cas type dha
calme dans certains quartiers je vais y
arriver
est ce que ça veut dire que les
parlementaires communistes vont déposer
des amendements à ce sujet dans la loi
cadre des oui je pense qu'il faut
profiter de la loi cadets qui je crois
doit être discuté ici au sénat au mois
de juillet pour décentraliser un certain
nombre de compétences vers les communes
c'est à dire qu'il faudrait que sur ce
sujet de la régulation des locations
touristiques de l'encadrement des loyers
aussi les collectivités locales et plus
de marge de manoeuvre
qu'on nous laisse faire et qu'on fasse
confiance aux élus locaux pour mettre
des règles qui permettent de mieux
réguler ce secteur je pense que ce
serait une très bonne chose donc vos
parlementaires déposées oui oui
absolument enfin je le suivrai en lien
avec eux et je me garderai bien de tenir
la plume
merci beaucoup merci d'avoir été notre
invité merci pascal eindhoven matin oui
mais c'est l'épilogué d'un staff est
remis en fait du moins pour ce qui est
de la petite fille donc été retrouvés en
suisse
rappelons le avec sa mère et puis toutes
les questions quand même que pose cette
affaire notamment sur le survivalisme le
complotisme il y à des enquêtes en cours
qui sont très sérieuses et c'est à lire
dans vosges matin merci messieurs
[Musique]